[Musique]
la FRCA le département de La Réunion le
syndicat du sucre de la Réunion vous
présente terre
[Musique]
d'ici donc voilà donc là on a de
l'ORE et là on a du blé donc le blé est
un peu plus petit parce que il va avoir
un besoin d'un jour de plus par rapport
à l'âge pour des graines de céréales
germé tout simplement voilà sans doute
l'une des solutions pour produire demain
du fourrage de qualité pour les animaux
d'élevage on est miette et on donne
TelQuel aux animaux en plus de de la
ration normale
de de fourrage en partenariat avec l'ARP
l'association réunionnaise de
pastoralisme et l'urcopa la scarevia
expérimente depuis plusieurs mois
maintenant cette technique hydroponique
de production de fourrage hors sol on
ninente pas les choses hein ce sont des
choses qui existent de par le monde et
sur lequel on avait aucune référence
française en la matière et l'idée c'est
vraiment pouvoir avoir et le tester sur
le département de La Réunion on est
confronté à des épisodes de sécheresse
relativement chronique on est confronté
à des problématiques de manque de
fourrage on est confronté aussi à une
problématique d'eau de réduction et
d'économie d'eau donc voilà un petit peu
l'idée pourquoi la germer pourquoi
éventuellement ça vaut peut-être le coup
de s'y intéresser et d'y regarder un peu
de plus près après une nuit de trempage
dans l'eau les graines d'orge ou de blé
sont mises à germer pendant quelques
jours au bout de 6 jours on va pouvoir
récolter le plateau d'Herb donc qui est
composé des racines des graines et des
plantules de de 7 jours donc là on a un
tapis végétal qui a 7
et on donne le tapis dans son entireté à
à manger à l'animal l'animal mange
toutien perdu l'avantage c'est qu'il y a
rien de perdu il y a rien de perdu tout
est consommé pour Guy Noë Picard éleveur
de mouton ce fourrage hydroponique
présente des qualités nutritives très
intéressantes pour ces animaux et c'est
surtout sur mes brobis qui ont un petit
c'est là que je vois la différence parce
que la brobie non seulement elle gagne
plus de lait donc le petit der il pousse
beaucoup mieux avec un une laine
beaucoup plus jolie et la brobie au lieu
de maigrir elle prend du poids alors
qu'elle a un petit c'est c'est
l'idéal c'est intéressant mais après
tout dépend le coup qu'il y a pour pour
l'éleveur qui qui peut investir par qu'
un petit module quand je vois le petit
module qui est derriè pour nourrir s
brugby B c'est c'est vraiment
intéressant si c'est efficace bon ben je
pense qu'il y aura pas mal de personnes
qui va aller vers ça parce que vu les
sécheresses et tout ce qu' a à la
Réunion au niveau climatique c'est
quelque chose vraiment d'intéressant
mais après ça
[Musique]
étudié du fourrage hydroponique pour les
troupeaux réunionnés l'idée en tout cas
fait son chemin à l'initiative de la
sicarevia plusieurs éleveurs de moutons
et de bœuf pays actuellement les
qualités de ce fourrage produit hors sol
c'est une technique qui repose sur le
principe de la graine germée donc on
fait on sème un tapis de grain qu'on met
à germer dans des plateaux pendant 6 à
10 jours et qu'on récolte au bout de ce
terme c'est une technique qui existe
depuis les années 1930 et qui a connu un
regain d'intérêt depuis le début des
années 2000 souvent pour répondre à des
problèmes de manque de de foncier et de
de sécheresse donc pour essayer de
répondre à des problèmes de de manque de
fourrage lié à la sécheresse développé
notamment en Australie en Inde ou encore
en Amérique latine cette technique
innovante intéresse aujourd'hui les
responsables des différentes filières
locales
d'élevage c'est l'innovation si ça peut
apporter un plus à la nourriture de de
no de nos troupau ça sera très bien vu
qu'on est en manque de fourage donc on
répond à la problématique on pourrait
répondre à la problématique du manque de
fourage de la Réunion ce module là il a
été conçu pour alimenter une centaine de
breobis ou une dizaine de vaches ou une
dizaine de chevaux donc c'est un
appareil qui va produire l'équivalent de
2000 m² de Chloris irrigué ou
l'équivalent de 4000 m car de kikou
premier concernés les éleveurs chez qui
sont menés ces essais mesurent déjà la
qualité de ce fourrage
hydroponique on a pris de lots un lot
témoin et un lot à laissé et pour le
moment bon il y a il y a il y a 200 250
g de décalage par rapport les deux les
deux essais en faveur de l'hydroponique
peut-être qu'on va travailler pour que
cetable là remplace quelque chose mais
il faut qu'on a vraiment les les données
correctes pour pouvoir faire une
alimentation équilibrée euh qui
viendrait je sais pas peut-être baisser
en nombre de kilos de foin ou baisser en
kilo de graines qu'on donne
mais déjà au niveau santé ça ramène
beaucoup en attendant c'est autour d'un
bon pquenique qu'on vit
sonrvés pour dégust cet excellent AG
pay comment est jolie la bouche encore
meilleure bouch faut qu'il joue le jeu
de l'an au pays et je suis sûr que comme
nous on sera pas on sera pas déçu tout
le monde sera gagnant et après celui qui
sera encore plus gagnant c'est celui qui
va passer à
table
[Musique]